(Momoland members harmonize "Momoland")
(quirky music)
- Hi, it's Evan here.
Today, I'm hanging out with Momoland.
(Momoland members cheer)
- Ow.
- Hi, I'm Ahin from Momoland.
Nice to meet you.
(blows kiss)
- I'm Jane.
- Hello, my name is
Taeha, nice to meet you.
- Hi, I'm JooE.
- Hi, I'm the lovely Nancy.
- Hello, I'm Yeonwoo.
- Is Jane okay here?
(Jane coughs)
- Today, they're gonna
be taking the BFF test
to see who is the ultimate BFF.
- I'm sorry.
- Who is the mom of the group?
- JooE.
We don't have one.
JooE, JooE.
- Yay!
- Who is the most unorganized member?
(laughing)
- Cheating, cheating skill.
- Jane, Yeonwoo.
And Yeonwoo.
Yeonwoo, Yeonwoo, Lee Da Bin, Yeonwoo.
- Who sleeps the most?
(laughing)
- Taeha, Ahin, Taeha.
Ahin, Ahin, JooE.
- Jane.
- Jane,
Me, Jane, Jane, Jane, Taeha.
(Nancy laughs)
(Nancy and Yeonwoo laughing)
- What is one thing that
Yeonwoo draws the most?
(Evan speaks in Korean)
(JooE and Yeonwoo make buzzer
noises with their mouths)
(Momoland members cheer)
(Evan speaks in Korean)
(jazz music)
- If Jane could go
on a vacation to any
country, where would it be?
(Evan speaks in Korean)
- France.
Japan.
(Evan speaks in Korean)
What is one food that Taeha cannot resist?
(Taeha cries dramatically)
(Evan speaks in Korean)
(cheering)
What would Taeha say if you asked her
to loan you a million dollars?
(laughing)
(Evan speaks in Korean)
- Whoa!
- What does JooE imitate the best?
- Mommy.
(laughing)
(gasps)
- Which sports is Cindy most confident at?
(Evan speaks in Korean)
Basketball.
- Yay!
- Nancy, you like cheese?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
What is Nancy's absolute
favorite cheese kind?
The list goes on.
- Mozzarella.
(cheering)
- I love cheese.
- Everywhere I go if I
say I have to do this
then I do it with Gudak.
This is really cool, it comes
out after like three days.
(upbeat music)
- Seven. Jane and I won.
- Yeah.
- Woo!
(gasps)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.